are those people who believe in the
transformative experience of
psychedelics somehow religious even if
they're let's say one of those types who
would be on the more atheistic end
because the psychedelics have this
quality of you ingest it sometimes you
encounter some other being but you don't
have to necessarily ascribe that to an
objective reality maybe that's the
union unconscious or just the
unconscious without a union flare
showing up and it's certainly
transformative there's data about that
does one who believes in the efficacy of
psychedelics have some religiosity to
them just because like i mentioned
there's that criteria of transformative
experience that radically
yeah so um in the history of uh
religious studies we could say
absolutely um could we say that now
uh of like european people european
white people i guess you know americans
canadians who go down to brazil or
central america and do ayahuasca and
then see
beings and things like that and then
come back transformed but maybe don't
believe in the objective reality of
those beings okay so i would say that's
not religious that's you know
that's transformative no doubt um but
within indigenous cultures
especially like with native american the
native american church and they use
peyote in order to get in touch with
what they believe to be presences that
are sacred and then that absolutely
transforms them and informs them as well
and that's a religion okay and you can
also see this within um
even different forms of catholicism in
oaxaca mexico so if you look at somebody
like maria sabina who you probably don't
know
but everybody should know about her
because she's fascinating so she's one
of the most fake she is the most famous
healer in mexico and i believe she died
in the 1980s but um
her whole life she was uh she used
psilocybin to heal people
and people came from all over mexico to
be healed by her and she called the the
beings that she believed she was in
contact through eating psilocybin or
drinking psilocybin tea
she called these beings little saints
and that's absolutely a religion right
there and in fact believe it or not it's
a it's a denomination it's a form of
catholicism okay and so you can even see
cathedrals down in oaxaca that actually
have mushrooms put into them because
they were built by the indigenous people
and this was part of their religion so
when the spanish came and said you know
build this cathedral for us they had no
clue that they were actually in laying
all these like you know mushrooms in the
architecture and you can actually go
down still and see that so yeah so this
arises i mean it could be a religion
curve do you see what i'm saying it just
depends on whether or not you believe
that it's a an objective reality that's
what a religion has it has this idea
that there's something it's not
subjective there's no subjective
transformation there's both an objective
reality that transforms you subjectively
and then you become transformed but this
thing is objective now i know people who
are people here in north america who do
ayahuasca together have the same visions
even though they don't talk to each
other and that reinforces their belief
that there's an objective reality to
this ayahuasca and they form churches
around this okay so yeah so there's a
lot of religion going on in there
whether or not you can discreetly say
this is a discreet religion and this is
why it's just much more vague than that
i know you're a scientist so this is
kind of like you know it it's just not
as cut and dry as we like to say you
know this is a religion and this is not
a religion um there are you know it's
it's um i think it has to do with the
objective reality of the you know
whether or not these people believe it's
objectively true
and again it could be or it could not be
i don't know we don't actually weigh in
on that but i think it's fascinating
that's part of the reason i find ufos
fascinating is because at this moment in
time what do we have we do have like
people who are coming out scientists
like dr gary nolan who by the way was in
american cosmic he's james in american
cosmic um my book and i traveled around
with him and he has a sports car
yeah he's got
i think he has a new one now um
but he had one back then too
and um
so well that kind of like threw me off
of what i was going to say i'm so sorry
[Laughter]
you're saying so there's credible
scientists yeah yeah okay so you have
people yeah and you also have you know
these big news outlets that people trust
for good or bad right like new york
times and things like that and they're
basically saying yeah this is real you
know these things exist and they're real
so to me as a person who studies
religion this is the first time in my
life that i've actually seen something
that's religious like this religiosity
that's hooking onto
an objective reality and this is
transforming people
right as we speak and so i think that
you know carl jung back in the day you
know a long time ago in the 1940s he
basically said how lucky are we that we
get to now see we ne we get to now be at
the very beginning of this new belief
system little did he know how intense it
was gonna get right
and so that's uh i think that we're at a
really fascinating point and as lucky
for me i feel like i caught the wave of
it right before it happened i caught it
with american cosmic in and believe me i
took heat for it so you know i'm here
hanging out with gary noland from
stanford you know we're going into the
new mexico desert with somebody somebody
who is affiliated with our space program
and basically
using these medical med uh metal
detectors looking for this debris from
crash saucers right uh at a site that's
not roswell but is one of the sites
that's you know where a crash is
supposed to have landed in the 1940s now
to me this was all a myth right and i
was going out there to understand how
somebody as amazing as gary and as
amazing as tyler who i call him in my
book he hasn't come out as gary's come
out as himself so i can talk about them
but the other person hasn't i'm like how
do these people who are obviously
rational
how are they believing this that was my
question because this is truly strange
and
i was just i felt like i was a walking
question mark like constantly just what
you know what is are you kidding you
really believe this yes they really
believe this in fact they they put these
you know things into different types of
microscopes and you know they looked at
these in different ways and they were
like yeah this is a these these parts
are anomalous and we believe that
they're
they're not earthly and things like that
i mean it was pretty crazy so to me
this is now
uh becoming something that's being
almost like mass marketed like through
media because you know now we don't have
the same type of media that we had in
the 1950s and 60s where things were slow
things are almost instantaneous now so
when dr gary nolan would say publishes a
paper boom everybody reads it right and
now everybody has this knowledge and so
we're seeing kind of like um
a bunch of changes happening at once and
i find it fascinating for religion for
this kind of
what i call religiosity it's definitely
not a religion in it in the old time way
i believe it's a it's the formation of a
new type of transcendent religion